Leigha the hunting dog and his owner
photographer Miguel Vorenus have lots in
common
for instance they both prefer to be
outdoors how much do animals and people
resemble each other many dog owners have
pondered that question and Miguel
Vorenus has devoted a whole photo series
to it
his first model was Leo of course
dan yeager Celestia I see him as a
serious respectable gentleman that's why
I designed the photo in dark colors so
that his facial features are easily
recognized in the viewers gaze is drawn
directly to his eyes I imagined I was a
painter and senior Leo would pose as my
model for a long time she didn't amici
Sima temple the goodness peerless or
second skins is the title of a ena
series about the similarities between
humans and other animals and about the
signals that clothes and gestures
broadcast Venus is an acute observer of
people in his hometown medina de campo
in northern Spain that's how he's able
to give his animal such human character
in this portrait I continued the rabbits
fur in the rabbit fur stole it's wearing
the way an elegant lady would wear it
the fawn isn't exactly childish but it
is rather delicate and recalls a small
girl with her little hand back the
series comprises 43 portraits pnina's
worked on it for half a year in my work
I'd like to control everything as far as
possible that's very important to me
lighting the gestures the staging the
clothing the coloration I like to
implement my idea precisely the way I
imagined it that's why the final
portraits are created on the computer
for the bodies and the pictures Bain has
photographs himself or friends
the heads are usually photos of stuffed
animals he alters the images on the
computer the way a painter uses brushes
and colors actually I'm a frustrated
painter I like to paint but I never had
the patience to wait until a painting is
finished that's why I made the mistake
of choosing photography as my medium I
thought all you were to do was release
the shutter and you'd have a result only
later did I realize that photography
also requires lots of preparation and
isn't as spontaneous as you might think
Miguel vanina's carries out experiments
with his own image as well for example
imagining and presenting himself in a
variety of professions as he might look
if his life had taken a different turn
he comes to the conclusion that his job
as a photographer for commercials isn't
so bad and when he needs a break from
his job he photographs landscapes
Silencio Blanco white silence is the
title of a series currently on display
in many shop windows in Medina del Campo
cereal of variety can I finish a series
that was a big strain I go out into
nature and then take pictures there I
enjoy a landscaped it's empty of people
or I can be alone with my camera and
nature I enjoyed it
Sam Arsenault code is protected
these are the moments when he can relax
and give free rein to his imagination
and where he creates his wonderful
worlds of animals and humans
you